mais régime pour maigrir prennent une
place de plus en plus importante dans la
vie des français journaux revues médecin
tout le monde donne des recettes
miracles et dans la rue chaque français
a un truc pour garder la qu'est-ce que
vous faites comme régime mais j'ai fait
on fera ce que j'ai fait un saut à
manger je fais le disons attention à ce
que je mange quoi d'après deux docteurs
qui me l'a dit il m'a dit de le
comprendre de boissons surtout et les
pilotes doit son nom de boissons de
poisson le vendredi à londres a dit oui
c'est ça jamais de boissons le vendredi
même poisson vendredi à les balais
glucose non pourquoi ni les clues cause
ni les protides monsieur d'une question
de goût qu'est ce que vous préconisez
comme régime vous moi
la droite toujours un la droite est ce
que votre avis le régime actuel va
continuer à perdre du poids oh oui oh
oui oui oui oui oui avec la carotte est
un légume vert donc c'est un légume
amaigrissant oui mais alors donc la
carotte est un légume vert
c'est un vécu oui bon vu le médecin
sahel feu vert pour la carotte jeu d'un
plaisantin messieurs mais je vous
connais
entre tous ces régimes il faut choisir
et pour perdre un très très léger début
d'embonpoint nous sommes rendus dans une
salle de gymnastique spécialisé en
maintenant il faut manger sainement ça
maintenant je vais manger sainement
maintenant on allait manger sainement
que ce que je peux manger manger des
légumes sans légumes légumes parce que
le légume peut être avec un petit peu de
viande outre même type en garde si vous
vous des joueurs sortent quand même
court ici les petits dongo est ce qu'on
peut mettre des petites pommes de terre
et des petites pommes et et à manger des
petites pommes de terre mais pas de mal
non c'est pas de mal et est-ce qu'on
peut mettre de la moutarderie vous
voulez c'est ce que c'est un légume par
exemple du chou quelques petites pommes
de terre de tous petits morceaux de
viande est un peu de moutarde voilà un
plat qui ne peut en aucun cas vous faire
grossir à condition de boire beaucoup
car tous les médecins vous le dise pour
maigrir il faut boire énormément
[Musique]
l'ennemi de la ligne c'est le sucre ne
mettez plus de sucre dans votre café le
matin est comme nous remplacez le par un
morceau de beurre
et puis faites comme nous si vous voulez
maigrir n'hésitez surtout pas à sauter
un repas
juste avant de manger si vous suivez
bien nos conseils vous avez une chance
de devenir aussi beau que le ravissant
jeune homme que vous voyez sur votre
écran
[Musique]